así es nosotros nos encontramos al lado
de la casa blanca es muy difícil verla
debido a las barreras que han colocado
de rejas y también de concreto para
proteger alrededor del servicio secreto
lo ha hecho pero desde la noche de ayer
seguidores más en su mayoría de joe
bayrén porque aquí en washington el 10 y
el 90% de la población está registrada
como demócrata han seguido minuto a
minuto los resultados de estas
elecciones tan ajustadas en varias
plazas en varias parques también se han
instalado pantallas grandes en donde la
gente y seguidores de bailén han seguido
estas resultados y también hay muy pocos
seguidores de trump si hemos visto
algunos han asegurado cuando
conversábamos con ellos que están
respaldando lo que dice el presidente de
que se ha robado digamos se ha hecho un
robo frente a estas elecciones y se
espera que también hemos comenzado a ver
cómo llega cada vez más gente a darse
cita acá frente a la casa blanca de
manera espontánea a la espera de que se
conozca quién será el próximo presidente
de los eeuu también pues la seguridad
está reforzada en todo el centro de la
ciudad
hoy no abrieron comercios y tampoco
oficinas